- Aujourd'hui, l'urgence
Rosemont déborde encore,
rororoblème chronique
dans plusieurs hôpitaux
du Québec.eseseseseseseseseseses
médecins d'urgence du Québec- O,
sur une base maintenant
quasi régulière, à des équ 1 1 %
de leur capacité.
- La crise perpétuellex x x x xy
assurer des soins sécuritaires.
- Ça devient dangereux
pour les patients, pour
les soins aue e e e e e e e e ee
pour donner des soins
à un certain nombre
de patients. Puis là, on
se r- Depuis des années,
plusieurs médecins le confiaient
à micro fermé. Mais voilà
que des médecins écrivent
le débordement chronique met
en danger la vie des patients.
Dans une lettre envoyée
aux directeurs d'établissements,
d'urgence du Québec écrit que :
- C'est très inquiétant.
mémémémédecins... des
urgentologues qui sont débordés.
- On va espérer qu'ilsrrrrrrrrrr
mort avant de réagir.- Entre 20,
la proportion de patients
sur civière qui attendeesesesese
de 17 à 22 %. Et avec
les vacances d'été
réduisent les services partout,
sauf aux urgences.
- Pour les prochaines semaines,
moist t t t t que la pression
soit répartie ailleurs.
- Les chefs d'urgence exigent
absorbent une part égale
bobobobobordements.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre, Santé
et Services sociaux, Québec l lé
est toujours difficile,mais je n
de mettre en place des choses
qui vont nous aider.dédédédédédé
Québec solidaire
- Si, effectivement, il y a eu
des morts évitables, c'est qu'il
y a quelque chose qui a vr
du ressort de la coroner.
- Mais les oppositions
que les urgences écopent
pour les autres échecs
du réseau.
Parti libéral du Québec
- Lorsque la Civivivivivivée
au pouvoir, il y avait 400 000
personnes qui attendaient
un médecinplplplplplplplplplplps
d'un million qui attendent.
comprend, c'est vraiment que
les chefs d'urgence
que les autres départements
partagent un peu le fardeau,
acceptent une pa
- Oui, les médecins d'urgence
disent queitititititititable
parce que pour donner
des vacances aux employés,
des vacaxexexexexexexexexexexex,
les chirurgies,
les s,s,s,s,s,s,s, que
les urgences qui ne peuvent pas
fermer écopent justement
s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s,
disent : répartissons
memememememement, la surcharge
équitablement, envoyons aussi
des patients dans lesêêêêêêêêêês
d'hébergement, en surcharge,lole
su
les chefs d'urgence
qu'à force de débordement,y y ys
évitables dans les urgences
du Québec.
- Oui, c'est eux qui le disent
lui, il pense qu'il y a
des solutions qui ont déj
été mises en place, mais est-ce
que ça peut vraiment améliorer
- Écoutez, le gouvernement
a mis sur pied un guichet
d'accès première ligne
qui se déploie graduellement
et qui fait en sorte que, u u ue
orphelin devrait pouvoir avoir
mememememememement un médecin
ou un autre professionnel de
la santé. Mais le problème, j'ai
l'impression de me répéter, mais
ça reshohohohohohohohose :
c'est qu'il y a de plus en plus
de médecins qui partent à la
convaincre les infirmiers et les
dededededededede venir travaillr
toujours au bord du gouffre.
Donc, oui, le gouvernement
du Québec, comme d'ailleurs
fait face à un cercle vicieux
qui est difficil
par ce que c'est compliqué
d'attirer des employés lorsqu'on
essaie justement de faire
foncpipipipipipipipipitaux
qui sont au bord de la crise
à l'année longue ou à peu près.
- Oupopopopopopopopopour
les urgences, ça fait longtemps
qu'on en parle, et on n'a pas
Merci, David.